CONFUSION
Okay, we're going again, Tempai!
I had, um, what happened was I got an alert as well on my phone saying, severe thunderstorms,
it's gonna go all the way to the weekend, blah blah blah blah blah, and then I'm laying
in bed and I'm like, yeah, fuming mad, that I, uh, haven't, that I had to end stream early,
and then suddenly, dead silent, Tempai, it was dead silent, except for one, one thunder,
and it was like, completely dead, like, no wind, nothing, it was completely dead and
I was like, for real, like the forecast literally said it wasn't, it wasn't, it was gonna like
last a long time, and I was like, oh my gosh, but like, it was like flashing and everything
and then suddenly, dead silent, can you believe it?
Maybe I willed the storm away, but now we're gaming!
I'm so sorry though, that I had to end early, I have a very old, old, um, surge protector,
like, when I say old, I mean it's over, over ten years old, and so I don't, like, over
a decade, right?
I don't trust it to do, to do its job, oops, let's do the triple move, like, I was actually
so mad, Tempai, I, you have no idea, I was so mad that, that I had to end stream because
I just don't have, are you serious?
Yeah, you might max HP, pitch slap him, oh yeah, oh yeah, I might see, do you ever find
peaches XXX in the game, yes I did, which I assume was panties, oh, Bowser leveled up,
is Bowser better at magic or physical, I thought I missed stream, welcome back Mercy,
I'm glad to be back, I literally was, uh, super, super mad, super, super, super mad,
super mad that I had to end stream, I'm probably gonna have to like, get a new, new, new power
surge thing, cuz, that's ridiculous, right, docile, pitch slap, I was really upset, and
then suddenly, like, honestly, I was really upset, I was malding, I was literally malding
and begging, yeah, I wanna see my Tempai's, I miss them, I need them, I wanna play Mario
with them, and, suddenly it became quiet, like, extremely quiet, and then suddenly
the weather forecast said it, the storm would pass, and I was like, oh, alright, honestly,
I was a little peeved, right, I honestly should probably get, um, get a, let's do it again,
oh no, actually that was a one time thing, dang it, malded so much people, you're right,
I should take it off, I dislike this jester thing, like, come on, come on, yes,
oh, shit, I missed that, uh, never mind, did I say my timing was great, I lied,
I lied, I can literally just go by, wait, hold on, I actually need this platform, excuse me,
excuse me, excuse me, thank you,
oh my gosh, I hear the rain again, oh, I'm gonna ignore it,
oh, why are you doing this, why, you're so rude,
I'm gonna, bitch slap it,
he must boycott the weather, it doesn't sound like as bad as earlier though,
it doesn't sound as bad as earlier, earlier was definitely a, uh, a, uh,
I thought I could bounce on him and fight him,
it's malo off said he's being replaced, he's not being replaced, he's just being,
being, no, you're right,
oh,
yeah,
I was hoping you just weren't in the eye of the storm, I was hoping that too, it was, it was,
oh, insane, not gonna lie to you, it was kind of like, wow, it's always these guys, huh,
feel like I should use like more honey syrup,
yeah, you got a freebie, nice, I'm getting a lot of freebies,
yeah, look at my timing,
slap, slap, uh, that was, oh well, that's fine,
yeah,
whoa,
maneuvering, so good,
so
that's to say, take a look at booze, boosters family purchase in order from the oldest to youngest,
I don't remember, look, need key to get in,
oldest to youngest, oldest was you, right,
yeah,
you got an orb,
man,
I don't remember,
can I remind you, my mom's not here,
I gotta do this myself then,
there I go, be gone,
be gone, be gone, testes,
I don't remember the order, was it you,
it's okay, I'll battle all of them,
oh yeah, slap,
sometimes you finish the puzzle, sometimes you smash her, isn't you, no,
ooh, we did it,
I can't remember, ooh, level up anyways,
I think Mario's good at physical, right, I'm gonna just keep physical,
was it you,
then was it you,
yeah,
ah, we'll boost force it, we'll boost force it,
oh it's glad, I'm glad to know that,
Malo also, was it you,
my memory shot, aka I didn't pay attention,
ah, was it you, oh come on,
it doesn't reset, right,
oh it reset, shit, hold on,
um,
I remember one of the big mouths is the the latest one, right, did I look at you,
shit,
memory, goldfish memory right now, oh the rain stopped,
okay, you, you, yes,
it's not, it's not, it's not like going straight backwards, is it, I would start crying, but
I swear one of these open mouths was,
yeah okay, it wasn't as, as, as, as kind as before,
yeah, I only know you were in combinations now,
okay, you, then you, I'm assuming one of you, fuck,
I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna level up,
I'm gonna just keep leveling up, yeah, Gino, let's go, Gino was magic, right, magic
was like the best for him, right, I mean, I think he's supposed to be well-rounded too,
I can't, can't remember what I was looking at,
second from here,
um,
Gino's the glass canyon, I'm pretty sure that's also,
okay, thank you Charlie for the two, super, are you okay, yeah I'm okay,
of course I'm okay, I was a little madge, but you know, I'm, I'm okay,
I don't remember which one I was looking at,
chip, root force, literal root force,
oh, my timing was off,
first, first, second, middle,
the, this one, yes, this one, then this one,
yay, I did it,
found the outer key, it's over here,
wait, what's over here, oh wait, it's a fun house, so, is that a thwomp,
thwomp,
oh, there's platform here,
oops, my timing is so bad,
did I mention my timing's really bad,
I'm not, I'm not just crazy and going through places, right,
I'm not just going crazy through places, right,
okay, there's a thing here, yeah, I don't know how it goes,
oh, I never, I can just look right,
kind of chain chomp,
I even reached there,
they gaze into each other's eyes,
Mario, she's a bit shy, look the other way, will you,
you can turn around now, she says she's been locked up here ever since she took a bite out of
booster, so now, she wants to help us stir up a little trouble,
whoa,
got chain chomp, anything else here, no, no,
maybe I should add the new weapon,
equipped,
sure, chain chomp, wait, I don't have anything for you,
wait, I didn't have anything for Bowser, oh, it's okay,
oh, hey, we're so back, yeah, oops, forgot,
we're back, everyone, the weather literally changed all of a sudden,
I was actually quite happy about it,
literally, it was suddenly dead quiet, I can't believe it,
I'm probably gonna have to buy a surge protector though,
especially if this is a common occurrence now, usually, where I live, storms are not,
I don't trust this blue area,
lucky, that's a lucky,
WREXP, challenge the system, win it big or lose it all, okay, where's Yoshi,
yeah,
oh, you got zoom shoes,
zoomie shoes,
can someone who can wear that one, yeah, Bowser, have your zoomie shoes,
your zoomer shoes, gambling always pays off,
oops,
sure, we'll do it again,
we love gambling and shoes,
maybe my eyes are so fast, I saw it,
oh, shit, that was not good at all, okay,
oh, I can't block that, oh no, Bowser,
okay, okay, Bowser,
you are really enjoying this game, aren't you, Mercy, oh yeah, I am, oh yeah, I'm having a great time,
oh, look at you, you're going so fast, yeah, physical,
oh, we have to,
okay, okay, okay, okay,
jump,
oh,
all right, it's not gonna work on you, not bad,
you know, beam,
oh,
yeah,
oh, get up there, wow, bite you,
I like the chest gesture,
yeah,
oh, this is my personal real life, he's so cute,
nice, you again, I'm amazed you made it this far, yes, quite amazing you are,
this year here, maybe you could clear up something for me, my bride to be is chanting,
Mario, help me, Mario, help me, is she showing her happiness,
hey a second, maybe Mario is another guy, what is this Mario, what if you're this Mario she
keeps talking about, oh, I don't know, maybe not, try and take my bride away, why don't you take this
instead,
hey look, I'm a guy,
I didn't do it, I ran out of bombs,
oh, so long,
you know, he's so sad, look at me, I'm a great portrait,
screenshot button,
cute, he's so cute though, I don't know, I think he's kind of cute,
my, my timing's still off on this,
oh, can't block that, there we go,
nothing else, okay let's go in, save point,
oh, oh no, am I bad at jump, no, I'm great at jump, jump is like my, my life,
jump is my life,
that's a beetle, oh it's a beach doll,
oh there's a Mario doll right there,
Mario, you did come to rescue me, I was so frightened and lonely,
and now you're here,
and I won't open, I think we need Booster's spell tender, undo the lock on it, oh what do we,
what should we do,
Booster's room turning, isn't he, I know hide somewhere and wait until he opens the door,
ain't no fucking way, he can move freely behind the curtain,
good luck hiding from Booster and his sniffsters, no,
what careful this part has inadvertently docked several vtubers in the past,
huh, don't worry my account name is as messy, right,
how's it gonna dox me is just my account name right,
boss shouldn't you be concentrating on the girl,
right, about the girl, now about the girl in my life, who thinks I should marry her,
well speak up, a wins ceremony would make a great party,
ah party, we should have had one of those, this could be fun, so what's a party,
oh you drink punch and eat cake I think,
hmm drink punch eat cake, sounds complicated, I don't know if I can muster the energy to do it,
let's walk it through, once it's swim rehearsal time,
now we will begin the ceremony, walk down the aisle, hey someone make her smile, beautiful bride to be,
wait are you already shows up from about now to ruin the fun,
wait hopefully your switch name is mercy and not anything else right,
my switch has a name,
um,
give me a second, we're gonna do something called I'm gonna figure out what I named it,
we're gonna figure out what I named it,
oh I tell what I named it,
is it the console nickname,
hold on, this doesn't really dox me when I'm still gonna change it,
um,
it's my account name for my switch account,
hmm,
if it's like my nintendo account that might be a problem, but my nintendo account is another one,
well when the most small black it when it gets to that point okay,
gotta take into that consideration you know, someone go and get the mario doll,
in here,
of course it's here you lazy slobs you couldn't find water if you were fish,
behind those curtains, number one you go take a look, oh shit,
oh,
nope, nothing here,
I wouldn't go and lose my mario doll you idiots, ah number two you should look too, oh fuck,
oh,
I don't see anything,
we can't give up gotta be here somewhere, number three is your turn, fuck,
whoa,
wait a minute this is better than a party, look out, because here I come,
wait a second that's right up there I found the mario doll,
it does kind of look fun, yeah actually,
I will never be able to reach up there, oh the sorrow, what am I gonna do,
I'm about to lose it,
oh it's crying,
goodness you're so kind, thank you for getting my doll,
oh it's so cute, oh no, I love him,
he's like a little baby,
I'd like to reward you here take this, got boosters charm, be happy to follow you wherever you go,
all right enough is enough, cancel the rehearsal, we're going on with the show,
here's the password,
it was mercy,
scream for mercy,
hey,
not mercy, oh no, I mean, whoa, it's a me, mercy,
can I touch the mario doll,
I want the beetle too, I jump on the beetle, can I go down,
no, oh poor beetle though,
whoa, who are you, you all took the trouble to come here, so stick around,
oh we got some tricks,
seen some vtubers got their real name shouted on stream,
well luckily I have gone through,
I don't know what the word is, but I've gone through everything senpai,
I've gone through everything and made sure everything was changed to be, it's a me, mercy,
I want my, my barriers are clean and I am cool,
I leave no, no traces, yeah,
here for your lives,
okay,
oh, I, oh I can't do that, okay, great guy,
nice guy,
it's okay, you can attack mario,
there you go, one guy gone,
oh you fell asleep, oh guino beam let's go,
yeah, money,
hey,
wait where are we going, oh she's getting carried away,
where's my bride to be, I'll play hide and seek too,
yeah, I don't want to play anything with you, what a poor sport, well we should really hurry
along, a yummy cake is waiting for us after we climb this hill, let's go, no I don't want to
marry you please let me go, oh mario please help me, oh oh it's mario we didn't plan on this,
mario you are invited to our wedding,
besides we still have the rehearsal, I'll be happy to race you to the wedding hall,
like you better not get in my way, oh, oh racing I didn't sign up for that,
I can't believe it, we like we were pals, ready,
thank you, thank you Sam for the super chat, I finished your bad advice spot earlier,
wow that old stream, wow it was like a month ago,
I was wondering if you ever do a male fashion advice stream since you're a fashion designer,
let me think, I would but I feel like everyone will be mad at me about my advice,
like worse than my my advice stream, because my fashion advice would be like,
everybody would be like no we don't agree,
do it anyways,
bad advice part two electric boogaloo, I think everyone should wear banana hammocks,
hahaha,
tasting fashion subjective anyways, yeah pretty much like if I were to do a serious fashion thing I
would do like things like regarding face shape and like uh build I guess, and then things that
will complement that, but I also don't want to like tell people like no you can't dress like this,
because like, you can dress whatever the heck you want, man.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Or good advice, like cargo pants 100% of the time.
Yes, cargo pants, uh, with the, the, the,
the Zelda, the green Zelda shirt.
And, uh, Crocs.
Yeah.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Okay, let's continue.
Ha ha ha, I'm being a little silly, bolly.
Wait, you're just trying to get me to transition into a girl?
I would tell you to wear programmer socks and a mini skirt if I wanted you to do that.
Oh and cat ears.
Stripe socks, baby!
Honestly, honestly wear whatever you want.
I know it's a stereotype, but honestly wear whatever you want.
Seriously, it doesn't really matter unless it's like, you know, you're going to a funeral
then maybe you should probably dress a little like respectfully, you know?
But what if I already wear the stripe socks, this is over, you're already in programmer
hell.
Can I wear my Mario t-shirt to a funeral?
Probably not, unless like, you know, the person you're going to the funeral floor was like
yeah, wear your Mario shirt and you're in their last will.
Like my personal fashion senpai, my personal fashion especially for comfort at home is
oversized shirts and hoodies, okay?
So like I will buy oversized t-shirts and stuff and just like lounge and my shoe that
I want are like slippers.
That's like my personal preference.
But like if I want to like look nice and pretty when I go out I would like wear a dress and
like, I guess, I guess like I like pastel colors, yeah.
That's my personal preference.
But for senpais I will wear like, you know, golf, golf clothes if you want me.
But like personally, I am a slob so I would wear like a t-shirt or like a nightgown and
just be like, yeah, this is the life.
Do you need some advice?
Yeah, I need some advice.
Oh, I need some advice?
You can only move left or right and jump.
You can't go forward or backwards.
Okay, do I jump like?
Touch the sips sners or any of the bear, Rosen you'll fall back.
Oh shit.
Jump on the barrels or the snifters to sprint forward.
Oh, okay, like that.
Reach out and touch Princess Peach and you'll win flowers.
I love flowers.
Ready, set, go!
Oh shit.
Ah!
I suck at racing.
Oh shit.
That's all you hear from me is, oh shit, oh shit, ah, oh fuck!
Why is it red?
Ah!
I'm falling behind!
There's too much visual!
Oh shit.
There's too much going on visually.
I'm having, I'm having a time.
Ah!
Cored two flowers, wow, I suck.
I'm getting overstimulated.
Mercy, what type of flowers are your favorites?
I like all sorts of flowers.
I've been really into tulips lately.
Welcome to Marymore.
We have a lovely wedding hall and four-star hotel facilities.
Please enjoy your stay here.
What, you're seeking a man with a scraggly beard and weird helmet?
How could I forget him?
He's at the wedding hall.
Any more stuff here?
Stop.
Isn't this just splendid?
This place is heaven even for an origin famous.
You're safe.
Give me some stuff.
Hello, how may I help you?
I'd like to buy something.
Ah, buy, mid-mushroom?
No, don't need that.
Aw, glove.
Ah, double lamp.
That's a kick.
Take the chop.
No.
Happy shirt, pants, cape, shell.
Maybe we can do the happy shell.
Yeah, I won't do happy pants, too.
And a happy shirt.
Nurturing, overflow flowing with a power of love.
Sure?
I like...
Okay, let's see what we can equip.
Booster's charm.
Oh, my attack goes up.
That's kind of nice.
But my speed goes down.
I want that.
Hello.
Oh, how may I help you?
I'd like to buy some things.
That's the same thing?
Okay.
Hello, honey.
Please, can we stay at the suite, please?
Life's known for exquisite service, especially in the suite.
That's a tad pricey.
I love weddings.
There's so much food that I can eat.
Hello, how may I help you?
Oh, the flowers.
It's locked.
Man.
Get up on this person.
Oh, I'm so exhausted.
I heard there's a casino where you get big prizes,
but I can't find a place.
It really exists.
Wedding dresses are pretty.
I think wedding dresses are pretty,
but I also think it's like a waste of money.
Casino?
Wait, they shouldn't have told me that
because I would, you know?
And the best photographer around.
Would you like a wedding portrait?
Some people look like chefs going to the wedding hall, though.
Through the back.
Weird, huh?
Through the back, huh?
Sorry.
Looking around.
Making sure there's no goodies that I'm missing.
Okay.
We're about to begin the ceremony
when some kids in dark clothes kicked us out.
Help!
Oh, man.
Booster's weddings in progress.
We're barricading the door,
so don't even bother trying to sneak inside.
Well, that sucks.
Hey, I think that's the one who kicked us out.
Looks like he needs to go somewhere fast.
Must be a first, a perfect couple
who isn't going to live happily ever after.
I give up.
What's the guy with the scraggly beard?
He and Grinch's beach shirt.
No, don't tell me they're getting married!
Who's the cook who blew in screaming?
It's time for my wedding!
Who does he think he is?
It's supposed to be my wedding day.
All my plans have been ruined.
I would probably kill someone.
I'd probably kill someone.
Oh, my gosh!
Me!
Hi!
Hey, Gigi, it looks cute.
It is cute.
Oh, my Mario cosplay.
What do you mean cosplay?
It's a me, Mercy, y'all.
This is how I always look like.
No, I'm going to fix your wedding.
Weddings are beautiful, sacred things.
It was my dream to stay in the suite
after we got married.
That's it.
Oh, that's the exit.
Mercy, oh, do you wax your sweet stash
or does it grow in that way?
It's 100% polyester.
The back way, huh?
Is this the flap?
Oh, there it is.
Found it.
Oh, cake!
Big cake for the big wedding.
It must be a masterpiece.
Yeah, the groom to be ordered something special.
Wait till he sees this.
I'm stuck.
I'm going to do it!
I'm going to step on the cake!
What, what, what are you doing?
Oh, that's nice.
You just stepped on the...
You fools!
I'm going to do it again.
What are you doing?
Oh, that's nice.
You just stepped on the...
You fools!
Is it just going to be repeated?
Yeah, I'm a little rascal.
What can I say?
Oh, who goes there?
Looks like Maria, but the door shut tight.
Listen, mustache.
You and your overgrown turtle friend
can take a hike.
Go, scat.
Scat.
Scat mansion.
Make like Maria and jump out of here.
Get lost.
Oops, we've got a problem.
I'm going to go tell Booster.
I'm on a bunch.
They want to help me bust the store down
on the count of three.
We run together.
Timing's the key.
Ready?
Here we go.
Sorry, but I can't let you through.
Hold on.
Am I supposed to actually...
Ain't no fucking way!
Okay.
Oh, no.
This is going to be the worst.
Oh.
Oh, we did it!
Ooh, we get to save.
Booster, sir.
Mario's here.
You clowns, don't break a door down
when entering a room.
Shut it.
Shut it now.
Move it.
Mario, is that you, Mario?
I'm in here.
Hurry.
Get me out of here.
I will beach as soon as I save.
Sorry, I'm super late, Mercy.
I just got Drake to do something early.
I just got home.
Never apologize for being late or missing streams.
I understand.
Don't worry.
Pretty sure Mr. Mustache can't break in here,
but Turtle does look mean.
Could be trouble.
I have no idea what they're up against.
I'm lighting in a bottle.
I'm an earthquake in a can.
I'll open this in no time.
I have no idea what they're up against.
I'm lighting in a bottle.
I'm an earthquake in a can.
Open this in no time.
Oh.
Yay, we did it.
Oh, no.
No, her crown.
Ow.
Watch what you're doing.
I mean, ow.
Great.
I've dropped everything.
My shoes, my ring, my brooch, and my crown.
Booster, sir.
Booster, I am.
Don't bother me now.
Okay, everyone.
The bride is growing impatient.
Let the wedding begin.
Is this water coming from your eyes?
Are you licking my deer?
Is he drinking her tears?
He's drinking her tears.
Hey, salty.
Booster, sir, I believe the bride may be crying.
Crying.
Well, that's what people do when they're sad.
How disgusting.
That stuff must be curled up.
It tastes like the sea.
I wouldn't make her cry anyway.
I believe she's crying because she dropped some of her wedding gear.
Aha, of course, but those tears will ruin the cake.
Make her stop before Mario breaks in.
Wait, that's so rude of you.
Mario's already in.
Booster, sir, we need to find her things.
The wedding can't go on without them.
We're still waiting on the cake, too.
10 for a good buddy.
You find her stuff.
I'll move the ceremony forward.
Hurry.
Booster, sir, you're supposed to be on the right.
The bride could be on your left.
Just testing.
Like this, right?
She's still drinking her tears.
Booster, sir, I found the ring.
Booster, here's the brooch.
Booster, sir, I found the shoes.
Anyway, wasn't there one more thing?
You're right, the crown.
Oh, they're lighting candles.
Hurry and get back the accessory from the sniffsters and say Princess Peach.
If you're quick, something good might just happen.
Wait, how am I supposed to get it back from them?
Wait, what?
Wait, he's having the crown.
I found something, huh?
Wait a second.
I only counted zero things.
We need to find four more.
Wait, what?
Oh, oh, I just approached them.
Why?
Wait, what?
Did I get all of them?
Oh, he's wearing the crown.
Oh, here it is.
Hey, you're Mario.
So you come to crash my wedding, I presume?
Oh, so I had to jump on him.
You're finally here.
Sorry, I took a little long.
I thought I had to jump on them or something and fight them.
What is Bowser doing here?
What a waste of time.
I got bigger fish to fry.
I know I'm getting good hands when you're around, Mario.
Here's a kiss for my hero.
Oh, isn't that just great?
Why are you going to kiss him?
But I'm the one who saved your skin.
Me too.
I want a reward.
I'll take a kiss.
Give me a kiss.
Stop it, all of you.
I'm getting so confused.
This is for you, Mario.
Aw, I get kissed from both of them.
It feels like sandpaper.
What the?
Aw, that's so cute.
Actually, I like that better, you know?
I like this better.
Can we get no cold high kisses?
Now that's for the scrapbook.
Oh, she looks happy.
Hello, Mario.
Let's get back to the Mushroom Kingdom.
The Chancellor's waiting for us.
Sorry, I don't have to keep you waiting.
We've made the most amazing cake.
Wait, we made the most amazing cake.
You won't believe it.
I did play Mario, honestly.
I remember where, like, if you go in with the wedding dress, like Mario, I worked my
ass off to make sure Mario got the wedding dress.
And then Mario and then Bowser were like, you look great.
And I felt so happy at that moment.
I was like, I was so happy, you know?
It looks like a Christmas cake.
But there are a bride and groom.
There's everyone.
This is big trouble.
The bride is leaving.
You're taking the bride away.
But Sam won't be anyone's easy cake.
But this cannot be.
We worked hard.
We worked our day on it.
You fools.
I'm fighting them and the cake.
Stop it.
Stop, stop.
I'm going to hit the cake.
I love how their names tort.
I'm eating the cake.
Wait, that looks really cute.
That looks really cute, right?
That looks really cute.
The chain chop looked like it was eating the cake.
Anyways, I hate eggs.
So be gone, evil cake.
Wait, shit, I resisted.
Stop it.
Can I terrorize the cake?
Never mind.
Attack the cake.
Stop it.
Oh, there we go.
I got it.
Help.
Wow, this cake is like...
Wait a second.
That's not a bun cake.
You're right.
It's not.
Anyways, I hate cake.
I mean, I love vegan cake,
but I'm allergic to cake.
I hate cake, so I generally hate cake.
Ouch, what are you doing?
She has to hurt the cake's moving.
Why is this not moving?
Back to block.
No, it was moving.
Nice jump on the cake.
Nice.
Stop it.
I'm getting better.
Out, out, now what?
Jeff Dork, the cake is moving.
Stop no more of these.
No, really, truly, why would I lie?
Because you are idiot.
See, he's not moving.
The cake is alive, run.
See, I was right.
Wait, is it actually alive?
Ah!
Oh!
Ow!
Yes!
Ah, shit, I can't block that.
Okay, that's fine.
Maybe we gotta wait.
This boosters wedding cake.
I don't know if we nibble on it.
Hey, number one, where's my cake?
Looster, sir.
Here's a 70% chance of the object you're standing on.
The cake.
This thing's a cake?
Okay, everyone, here's the stumper.
How do we eat this?
I think we boil it.
What do you say?
What do you do messy?
How do we even just swallow it?
What, in one gulp?
That's easier said than done.
Come on, booster.
Can you do it open wide, please?
My nerves are shot.
Oh, man, oh, man.
I feel like I've forgotten to tie my cord before a bungee jump.
Here it comes.
Wait, wait.
Did the cake just move?
Concentrate, sir.
I don't even feel right.
Oh, he ate it all.
Delicious.
Oh, that's so cute.
Hang on.
I feel, I'm feeling, I'm feeling.
It's good.
It makes me want to cry.
Congratulations, sir.
The wedding is now officially over.
Thanks, everyone.
It's a wrap.
Let's go.
Aw, he did it.
Cover up.
Now I can use Firepaw.
More physical.
Mahalo, reach level 10.
Alert, shocker, magic.
That was wonderful, Mario.
You're my knight in shining armor.
Finally, let's get back.
What a day.
Can you believe it?
I almost got married to that thing.
I hope someone marries me someday.
Each princess of the Mushroom Kingdom has joined the party.
Be sure to bring her back safely.
Safely, huh?
Aw, it wasn't hard to save.
In terms of kidnapping, all of his goals were accomplished.
Was Booster more successful than Bowser?
I mean, he got his cake, so, and ate it too.
Mario.
That creepy guy just left.
Does that mean we can go on with our wedding?
Oh, Raz, I'm so happy.
Let's get this wedding over with so we can stay in the suite
and then go on our honeymoon.
Let's do it.
All right, you'll have to excuse us.
Hey, everyone.
We're going to start this from the beginning.
Back inside, please.
Can I crash their wedding?
Raz, he found himself a real peach.
I can't take it anymore.
So gorgeous.
He's so beautiful.
It's lovely, isn't it?
Right now.
I do.
Yes, indeed.
It's a melody of celebration.
Composed by the one and only Toad Voskey.
Oh, wait, that was Toad Voskey.
Oh, jump on him?
Let's do that, too.
What a lovely wedding.
I was like, I'm stuck between them.
Hey, what are you doing?
It's just for fun.
Oh, yeah, she does kind of scares me.
I wish people before us would hurry up.
We've been waiting for 30 minutes now.
Now the cake will stay put.
Don't worry, Chef Tork.
Don't love this.
What are you doing?
I stepped in the cake.
You fools.
You will get that play button.
How many subs is the gold button?
One million.
It's actually like, mama was like,
mama was like, do you remember?
Do you know the meme where the girl's trying to explain something to her mother?
Mama looked like that, trying to explain what a YouTuber is to papa.
It's so funny.
It was funny to see.
But, um...
I think she got...
She was like, oh yeah, they talked about gold buttons and silver buttons.
There was only a gold one, so now I'm just like...
Shit.
Like, she's getting it because she's been watching like...
She's been watching like, people explain it, right?
She's like, I don't know what you're doing, dear.
You know, I tried to explain to her what it was,
and I felt like it was wrong to be like, oh, you know...
You know, like, I'm...
It's wrong to be like, to let her continue believing that I was a teacher.
I mean, she did get that idea in.
Which is really funny, because she's been telling her friends,
she's like, oh yeah, my daughter's a YouTuber now.
And nobody's asked the channel,
which I'm a little bit grateful for.
Nobody has asked for the channel so far.
They're like, oh, that's nice.
Oh, how great of you.
How lucky you are to like, join a company doing this.
Like, literally, they're just like, oh yeah, we're really happy for you.
We're really happy for you.
This seems like such a glamorous job, but I bet it's hard work.
What's your big answer for what they do?
I would just be like, it's a secret.
Honestly, I'd probably just say it's a secret.
But like, so far, nobody's asked.
And I'm just like, a little like, oh, maybe they have a feeling
they're going to be really embarrassed about what I do.
So none of them are going to ask.
Honestly, I think it's better if they're kind of not really in the know,
like maybe just be like on the fringes of like understanding what it is.
But like, I feel like if Mama and Papa know, they would dox me like to everyone.
They would dox me to everyone.
As long as you get some privacy, right?
Yeah, privacy is not a choice.
Maybe just tell them that.
Like what?
Like I need some privacy to do it.
I like how you guys think that they respect my privacy.
But most of the things that I'm worried about,
Senpai is not the streaming stuff.
It's the side stuff that I'm worried about.
Being in the play button, won't it say Mercy Modi's channel VLR?
Yeah, but I can also order.
You can put like whatever in it, right?
I can just order another one that says like, you know,
you can customize them like you can put in like whatever for the channel name.
Like that.
So I mean it costs more to get like extras, but
I might just put like a safer work name, I guess.
On there?
Side stuff like V-tweeting?
Yeah, although I feel like I don't tweet as much as my gen mates.
That's not, I'm not saying that they're like tweeting a lot.
It's just that I hate Twitter.
I hate Twitter.
I mean it would be sad to fake the plaque name.
I'll get like two or something maybe.
X is bad.
Why are you, why are you naming?
Why are you calling it X?
Dead name it for the rest of his life.
Shitter.
I think X is like the sound in like Chinese, right?
I don't like social media.
I'm probably the most, I'm the least social media person.
Oh yeah.
It's going to be held here, absolutely gorgeous.
I came to see where the wedding is going to be held.
For my honeymoon I was thinking of going to Seaside Town.
Oh that sounds nice.
Here, I'm sure it's ski season.
The best for a photographer, would you like a wedding portrait?
I like man and wife.
Honey, I don't want you to wander off too far now.
Oh man is it over yet?
I hate getting my picture taken.
I understand.
Okay a little closer now, ready?
Alright, one, two, hey you there.
And a long face, this is a new funeral you know.
Alright on count three say cheese.
There's those two on wonderful life, they don't fight too often.
Right down and relax.
It's nice to have a wedding.
Where's the guy that ran away though?
There's a little low guy that ran away.
I have photo bombing.
Besides, it's Mario, I'm practically a celebrity.
Right?
It's locked.
I want it not locked.
Say fuzzy pickles.
Wait, that's from, that's from, that's from the brothers game.
Actually I'm pretty, I'm looking forward to brother ship.
I know people are like, why is it called brother ship?
I'm like, isn't it cause they're on a ship?
My reaction is so plain.
Mario.
The chancellor's waiting, we're going back now right?
No.
Mario.
Chancellor must be worried sick about us.
It's on before, come on let's go.
No.
Wait, earthbound, no right, I played earthbound.
You're right, I played earthbound.
It was like hey, fuzzy pickles and then they take the picture.
And then yeah, I remember that, shit.
You're right, that's from earthbound, I played earthbound, wow.
Mario.
Don't go to princess back, we'll be charged with kidnapping, let's go.
No.
Mario.
No one, no one is authorized to kidnap the princess except me.
Just wouldn't be right, sticker back already.
Forget it.
Enough already.
Okay, I'm going to go.
What, I can't even go there?
Forget about it.
I can't believe Bowser's being the voice of reason, it's kind of cute.
Mario, welcome back, you look like you're in one piece.
Princess.
I'm finally home with Mario and some wonderful new friends.
I'm so glad you're here.
I'm finally home with Mario and some wonderful new friends, they saved my life.
Let's go find the chancellor.
Need on.
Come Mario, we must keep the chancellor waiting.
The one piece.
Chancellor, the princess, she's back.
Thank goodness this has been a true nightmare.
I'm nervous, I'm a nervous wreck.
I know I've worried everyone, but I'm fine, I can take care of myself.
With a little help from Mario.
Come everyone, let's get this out of the, let's get out of this drafty doorway.
Mario, I hope you know how thankful we are.
But you must tell me one thing, how on earth can you trust Bowser?
Trust Bowser?
What are you talking about?
Mario, what are you doing with?
What's going on here?
E-gads.
Chancellor, listen everyone, relax.
Mario's got things under control.
Y-yes, I see.
Bowser, perhaps this time you told us your story.
What exactly did you mean when you said, a bigger fish to fry?
Get down the truth, if this gets out, I finish.
Excuse me sir, perhaps I can set the stage, and the others can add their comments along the way.
Princess Bowser and Mario were thrown in different directions after a terrible explosion.
Something huge crashed through the star road, high above Bowser's place, and went, boom, right into Bowser's Keep.
Wait, Mario!
What's a gigantic sword?
Now Bowser's Keep has been taken over by monsters who work for some creep named Smithy.
They've thrown me out of my own, I mean, I've decided to take a vacation.
They can't do this to me.
Anyways, I was working on a plan to get my house back when Mario walked up to me and begged me to let him join my minions.
I had no choice but to let him in, I was pathetic.
No, no.
It's okay Mario, we know Bowser's stretching the truth a little.
And, Malo, what about you? Why are you traveling with Mario?
Well, because Mario's helping me find my real home, and my parents.
That's why we're on the road together.
What? That's stretch phone news? How horrible.
I hope you find your real parents soon.
And, um, you know, was it? Why are you and Mario?
The Homeowners Association got him, I know, right? Why do they do that?
Why are you taking away the home that I own?
The Star Road has been destroyed.
I'm here to fix it.
Mario is helping me search for the Star Pieces. I need them to rebuild the road.
Star Pieces?
Star Road grants our wishes, unless we find all the Star Pieces and fix the Star Road.
We can kiss our dreams goodbye.
What? This is stretch phone news? Awful, horrible.
Mario, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Awful, horrible.
Isn't it?
Indeed, for example, say Bowser kidnapped you.
Without the aid of the Star Road, you probably would never be rescued.
Actually, this sounds pretty good to me. Let's forget about the stars, things.
Great, Bowser. Then you can just kiss your precious key goodbye.
Oh, what?
Let's see if Mario can't find the stars.
Peach will be mine, and I won't get my key back unless Mario finds the star.
So if I want my key back, we need the star thing, but run that past me again.
Ugh, just ignore that idiot. I don't think I could take a world, take a world without wishes.
We need to go and find the Star Pieces now.
It's us.
You can't be serious, you're not. Wait, you can't be serious, you're not thinking of joining them, are you?
It's your madness, you're a princess, what will people say?
I don't care, things seem so hopeless right now.
I'm tired.
I need to lay down in my room for a while.
Mario, Malo, Dino, and Bowser, too. Good luck.
Now then. Thanks to Mario, the princess is back. I now declare the state to be known forever as...
Wait a minute, you don't suppose. Could have been Smithy who attacked our kingdom.
I feel we have no choice, no cause to rejoice. In fact, Mario must ask you yet another favor.
Why, they always gotta make me do favor, Senpai. How many times are you... come on!
Please, on behalf of all of us, you must defeat Smithy. The only way we'll ever live in pizza again.
Again, again.
Princess home. Princess Peach is home safe, but she has to stay at the kingdom.
I know, it's like... why is there a space up here? Can I go there one day?
I wanna go to Princess Peach's room.
Princess back, I humbled myself before you. Good luck, Mario.
I found her thingy here, which I assume are her panties. And this guy paid me off for them.
Haha.
Spend money on the casino.
Ah, you know, you know it. You know it, Senpai, we're gonna spend money, Mario.
Who's asking?
Oh, Peach! Oh, she's so cute.
Oh, Peach is always so cute.
Please, Mario, take me with you. Take me along with you, please.
Don't worry, Granny helped me through this one, so no one will ever notice that I'm gone.
Wait, that was Granny?
That stole, that stole, that stole the panties?
So let's find us a star.
I wonder where it could be. I have absolutely no idea, do you?
Mario, times like these?
What should we do?
She asked my grandpa, my grandpa should know.
Okay, then let's do it.
This is what I thought. Peach joins the party once again.
Yeah.
Wait, wait, wait. Hey, Mario, I can help, don't you now.
Progressive.
Alright!
He jumps faster.
Yeah, he definitely out jumps.
I want to jump on this kid's head.
Come on, let me jump on his head.
Be so fast.
And I'm also bad at platforming.
Yeah!
I got dizzy.
He's cute.
Okay, let's get the watch out of here.
Oh, I can go to Mario's house and I can get stuff, right?
That shout is so hyped on Kappy.
Yeah.
Here's my box.
Take Max.
Yeah.
Give me all my stuff.
Okay.
Take Max.
Yeah.
Give me all my stuff.
Whoa!
Wait, this is the wrong one.
This is the wrong one.
Epeco high?
A little bit.
There it is.
Table Pawn.
My bad.
Okay.
Come on, my bad.
Hey Grandpa, have you heard anything about the star pieces?
Well, what if...
Well, if it...
I could go.
Whoa.
No, I can't do it.
I can't do an old person voice right now.
I'm so bad right now.
Well, if it isn't...
I don't know.
Well, if it isn't Molo,
I do have the latest news about falling stars, in fact.
A large star has been sighted on Star Hill.
Star Hill?
It does sound...
Seemed likely that a star piece would fall there.
We should go explore Star Hill right away.
Star Hill, how obvious!
Okay, we're song?
It's the mobile minor song.
Hold on, I'm going to write this down.
Okay.
Mi, yo, so,
yo, re, la,
yi, yo.
It's got soul!
You want music lessons from moi?
Not yet.
Well, be that way.
Yeah, I know training continues,
but I'm also like,
oh, maybe I'm too tired for this soul right now.
Like, I have...
I'm like having those feelings where like,
oh, I'm starting to feel exhaustion.
Welcome to Frog Hall, wine and podium.
What are these party bracers?
Apokola,
or frog-like koala.
What can I buy with the frog coins?
Defense, attack power, defense...
This sounds handy for like, the final boss.
The EP sneaks up on you.
Yeah, it always sneaks up on me.
I think it's because I didn't spend like an hour before playing this.
And now I'm just like, oh.
Well, there's a star place right there.
Oh, so pretty!
To marry more,
talk the flower in the gate will open.
Star hill.
This flower?
Oh.
This is star hill.
Wishes which were transformed at the star road fall to here.
But some wishes that haven't been granted yet are falling
because Smithy destroyed the star road.
The frog sage mentioned a star piece on this hill.
Let's see if we can find it.
Oi!
What the fuck is that?
I don't trust you.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
I dubbed the skeleton.
That's a really cute name.
That's also really cute.
What the heck? These are all really cute.
Am I missing something?
I hope my baby's cute.
Can't wait to start a family.
I wish I had some cricket jam.
Am I supposed to fight everyone here?
How come it won't open?
I wish I weren't such a crybaby.
This one's private!
Who do you think you are spying on other people's wishes?
Come on, our quest for the star piece is important.
Everyone's counting on us, we've got to hurry!
Sorry about that, it's just I'm embarrassed about my wish.
Listen here, you little shits.
I become famous.
Fuck.
I'm a hunger roll for some food.
Relatable.
I want to be a blood class becker.
I think I know who that is.
I think I know who that wish is for.
Ooh, sneaky.
I want to be the best treasure hunter in the world.
Oh.
Please let Mao find his way home.
Wait, please let Mao find his way home.
Why, this wish is from my mom and dad.
They're wishing for me to come home.
This isn't time to be crying.
They're waiting for me to come home.
Come on, Mario.
We've got a busy schedule to keep.
I'll make you eat dust if you don't hurry.
That's really sweet.
Wait, did I go back?
I'm so sorry, I don't remember if I went backwards or something.
That was really sweet.
If I could only just get that melody.
That's Trevosky.
I mean Tozvosky.
Wish I could run faster.
That's the Yoshi probably.
I can't help my older brother, Mario.
Loloichi's wish!
I think I found the star.
Yay, star piece!
How many more left?
Looks like three more left.
So a star piece fell here after all.
Where to next then?
I think there's a place called Seaside Town up ahead.
But here it's a busy resort town.
So the people there might know something about it.
Let's go see!
You've come a long way, but your journey is not over yet.
There are three more star pieces.
Oh, am I missing one?
Yeah, I am.
There you go.
Oh, Seaside Town lets us gamble.
Sounds like a place where we can gamble!
That's a tentacle!
That's a zombie!
This is the end. You may stay for free.
Oh, pass.
Okay.
Hmm.
This is nothing of interest here.
Don't bother looking inside.
Uh-huh.
I'm gonna guess I can look inside.
Don't tell me you want supplies, I know.
Poison an enemy.
Fear attack on a single enemy.
Hit all enemies with fire.
Sure, I'll... Oh wait, 69! Nice!
Wait.
These are pricey, but also 69 nice.
Thank you very much.
Don't tell me you want supplies, I know.
That's the same thing.
I don't know what I was just doing there.
Exhaustion hitting middle ocean pirate ship.
To find out, I mean, there's a...
Pirate lives there, his name is Jonathan Jones.
He isn't very nice.
He's getting reminded, okay.
Star falling into the sea pirate, probably.
I mean, that man, Jonathan Jones, probably has a nasty...
I hope I sound...
I hope I sound dead inside some pie.
That's what I'm going for.
He's up there!
We're lacking stars, right? Only three more to go.
Want to enter the ocean, jump into the whirlpools.
You'll find the village elder in his house.
He's the most respected person here.
They keep spinning and spinning.
Ooh, stuff.
Things, houses.
Gymneys that I can't even go into? What is this?
What is this?
Finally, it took me long enough.
I'm the outer of this village.
I got my Exhaustion in life by leasing my superiors,
which is something I do well.
Stars fall into the ocean.
I needed for a certain purpose.
You'll find it for me.
There's a frog here!
Hello there, you're Mario, right?
Do you remember me? We met at Tapo Pond when I was still a tapo.
You turned into a little... you turned into a frog?
Wow!
I've graduated from Frog Sage's School
and now I'm searching for the meaning of life.
I've been so quiet around here, it's almost eerie.
What's going on?
He doesn't concern me, but if you have any frog coins I got,
I've got some neat items to sell.
See ya, run from battles.
Earlier times.
Using this will not consume it.
I want that! I want that!
I want that earlier time thing!
I want the earlier time thing.
We do need frog coins!
Yeah, that sounds like real good, you know?
Big area.
I want the battle start over thing.
I need two more, two more, right?
Did I go into every building there is?
I feel like I should be sneaking.
No casinos here.
No gambling.
See.
See these nuts.
Oh, hi.
I often people came around here.
Oh.
Cardi's refresh during battle.
Super hammer.
Womp glove.
Handgun.
Early glove.
Sailor shirt.
Sailor pants.
Sailor cape.
Sailor dress.
Here, have a dress.
I want these, I don't have enough money.
Shop here, I'll tell you this.
Chip sank into the briney sea because of a giant squid attack.
People went to survey it, but they never came back.
Huh.
Pretty sure I put clothes on Bowser.
See, I gave him some happy shell.
There.
Overflowing with power of love.
Therapy.
Think Bowser, Gino and Mario are probably the greatest.
Group, I guess.
Love ring for Peach is nice.
I love love too.
I am big dummy because I don't know how to get over there.
Oh, there's more over here.
Let's start.
Never mind.
That was my bad.
Oh, there's the squid thing, the bloopers.
Yay, terrorize him.
Oh, shit, I missed.
Yeah.
Thank you, Buzzbun for remembering.
Oh, I'm so eepy.
Can you tell that I'm getting like the eepers?
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, treasure.
Yeah.
Yay, another fraud coin.
We can afford starting battles over.
Oh, I can jump into the whirlpool.
What if I just want to look at things?
Senpai.
Wait, come back.
I need to get...
I need to...
Wait, how do I unswim myself?
I don't want to swim anymore.
I just want to go back on land.
Let me in.
Man.
I'm trying to jump out, it's not working.
Oh, this is nice.
I can't look at...
I don't want to get myself out.
Please, let me be free.
I can jump underwater.
Paige is from a travel log.
Let's take a look at it.
All right, done for it.
Giant squid just got a hold of us.
The ship's going down fast.
How do I get out of here?
How do I jump out?
Okay, that's nice.
Nice to know that works.
I went in here already, right?
Yes, I went in here already.
Got the stuff.
Okay.
I guess I wanted to go down here.
Wee.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, stuff.
Got Max Mushroom.
Nice.
Okay.
Ah.
Ow.
Cowards, they really ran for me.
There's fucking ghosts.
Thank you, saved point.
There's a page from the travel log.
Let's take a look at it.
You've managed to trap the giant squid in the treasure cellar.
The treasure will sink with the ship.
But so it goes.
Of course the ship's haunted.
Blah.
I wanted the save point.
Got to blame the ghosts.
The EP, Soul EP.
Epeist.
Page from travel log.
Okay.
Look at it.
Door to the cellar is locked with the six letter password.
To get inside you have to figure out
the password using six hints.
Come on.
Can I get up there?
I don't think so, right?
Uncover the secret of the six hints.
Since they're provided by different people,
it may be tough to solve.
It may be impossible.
Oops.
Eugh.
Ooh.
Okay, they do some pretty heavy damage, huh?
Okay.
Stop reaching!
Oh man, you are a glass cannon.
What the hell?
Get your HP up.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Whee.
Ooh, level up.
He should call.
Oh, what's Peach good at?
I didn't use Peach.
Maybe she's a magic girl?
Maybe she's a magic girly?
Okay.
Is Amy's rat?
Ow.
Okay.
Shit.
Wow, I suck at this.
You know what?
Oh.
Oh shit.
Get up.
I'm so epic.
Holy fucking shit, man.
I am...
My timing is so off right now.
I...
I must be that tired.
Yeah.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Understood.
Let's triple one of this.
Whoa.
You need to get to a save point first, right?
Is Motherfucker still alive?
Jeez, Louise.
Okay.
I'm so glad that we have the mushroom thing.
Yay, coin.
Whoa.
What is that?
Do I like hope?
Oh, nice.
And...
Here's Indigo Mem...
Well, there's an S in the word.
Okay.
I don't know if I can continue.
They're like, uh...
What was the map system again?
I think maybe I'll be okay.
Maybe I'll be okay.
Okay.
As long as we don't fucking die.
Yeah.
Okay.
Pull up.
Come on, Leo.
You should call.
What is that?
No.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Never mind, I did it.
Wow, I'm so smart.
Ventures Indigo Junior Memo.
It's found at the bed of the ocean.
Bed?
So what, like seaweed?
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah.
There we go.
Six letter words, sorry.
Feeling we're all feeling the eepers.
Trying to figure out...
where I am.
Okay.
Wait, where am I?
I thought this maze was neat.
I just can't fucking see, man.
Is it like...
Oh.
I got it.
Hee hee.
Okay.
Yeah.
I fucking did it.
Second Expedition Team Memos.
It has two vowels.
It has an S in it, two vowels.
And...
the bed...
ocean bed.
Oh, I have to go over there, okay.
Okay.
How strong are dry bones?
Fuck!
Bitch isn't dying!
I'm hitting real hard!
They're immortal unless you use certain things?
Yeah.
Maybe I gotta jump on them?
Really?
I mean, I have to take all of this?
I can't believe it.
I mean, it is a Mario game, just...
I didn't think that was the answer.
Okay.
Yay, level up.
Is this a bad guy?
Oh hey, it's good to see you.
Oh, I can buy stuff here.
I need some more of these.
Okay.
What do you hint?
The password's got something to do with the sea.
You don't get through all six of the obstacles.
You can try to deduce your way through.
Good luck.
Sand?
Oh shit.
No!
I think they're weak to that.
Money! Money, money, money!
Money?
Hey.
Wait! Wait, wait!
Shit.
Fuck.
Are these free money?
Did I get it?
Yeah.
Is it treasure?
Is it fucking treasure?
It's very valuable.
Yeah.
Is it treasure?
Is it fucking treasure?
It's very valuable.
Seven letters.
How many letters is treasure?
T-R-E-A-S-U-R-E-S-8, teaser!
You're right, it's very valuable.
Ah, life!
It's like seven letters, has an S, valuable, it's modi-
Ah, it's a-
A-T-A-S-I?
Oh, shit.
Oh, man.
A shocker.
There we go.
What is this?
Get the cannonball into the boxes, but how do I do that?
It's like a just on their own?
Oh, I see.
I have to start over.
I understand.
Fuck!
I am an idiot!
Idiot!
What the hell?
Ah, that perception!
Yes!
Fuck you.
The fourth investigation crew memo.
It is actually a they.
It's very valuable.
It's found in the ocean bed.
Oh.
Seven letter words?
Multiple?
Oyster sounds like a good-
Oh, shit.
Oyster sounds good, yeah.
Was it six letters?
Oh, shit.
I'll save point.
I might end here.
But also treasure.
Pearls?
Oh, yeah.
Pearls is nice.
Yeah, pearls.
Once you've come up with the key letters, speak it in here.
It spells it out.
Wait, what's the...
Wait, what's this?
How do I do this?
Do we know how to do this yet?
Wait, how do we do this puzzle?
Is this a lighter thing?
Oh.
Like, kick it or move it or...
Jump on the barrels?
Oh.
Wait, what are you even doing?
This is very difficult.
What?
Yay.
Our becomes... becomes the help.
We figured it out.
Oh, wait, I spelled it wrong.
Wait, P...
P...
R?
Wait, P...
Right, A.
What was it wrong?
R...
L...
That's what you're into.
I'm so stupid!
It's a PSLR.
Oh, my God.
P...
A...
R...
Yeah.
Good job.
I'll let you through.
Get past me first, that is.
Pass me first, that is.
P...
Give us a second.
Okay, we'll do this one last battle.
Fuck it.
Hold on, give me a second, I need...
My team up.
No, wait, Malo's better in this...
In this fight, I think.
Yeah, actually, but...
Fuck it, we fall.
Okay.
Triple move, baby!
I don't care.
Farage?
Wait, this is really cute.
Wait, that's really cute.
Ah!
Ha ha ha!
Oops!
Ow!
That's so rude.
That's really gross!
I want to make Kalamari!
Yeah!
Making Kalamari was wrong!
You can't kill me.
I did it!
Yeah!
Ah, making Calamari was right!
Wait, where'd my buddy go?
Uggghhh!
I don't have anything with fear.
Got a freebie!
Okay, let's get ourselves some... F.P.
Can't block that. Alright.
Okay.
Maybe I can switch him?
Oh, we'll see what P.E.S. can do.
F.P. group hug.
Yeah, group hug.
Okay.
Ugghhh!
Fuck.
Oh, she just slapped them! Alright!
Ugghhh!
Oh, come on, P.E.S.H.
Haha!
Ugghhh!
Can't duck that, huh?
Come on.
Ugghhh!
Yes, we did it!
Yeah!
What the heck is that?
Fuckin' rats.
Oh, come on.
Listen.
Fuckin' rats.
What's this one?
Okay, I wanna see what this is.
Ah, shit.
Ugghhh!
Fuckin' rats, they move so fast!
I am not lying to you when I said these rats move fast!
Come on. Oh, they poison you too?
Brutal.
Oh, come on.
Ugghhh!
Fuckin' rats!
Ah.
Ugghhh!
Oh, shit.
Can I not shoot it with that?
Easy call.
I wanna get up there.
Probably have to go to the other room.
Aw, man, I thought I would have a cool friend!
Fuck off.
I thought I had a cool friend!
I talked to myself all the time, too. Yeah, you understand.
She's an item, right? What was it, pure water?
Okay.
Yes, I did it.
I did it. I didn't even fuck up this time, this time.
Okay, the question is now, where do I go?
Oh, it's over here. Yeah.
Anything cool on this side?
Yeah.
A lot.
Bitch.
Ah.
Ugghhh!
You rude slut.
Aw, you slut!
Aw.
Mini Goombas were inside!
I got this.
Ugghhh!
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
Yay!
I'm gaming!
How do I get that to here?
Oh, my client, too.
Oh, shit.
Okay, now I can jump. The other time I didn't jump.
There it is.
Give me my stinking fraud coins!
Mario really has a set of lungs, huh?
Yeah. Aw, shit.
Shit.
Hey, I did it! I did it! I timed it correctly for once!
Haha.
Fuck.
He's dancing!
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Magic.
How do I get out of here?
Why are there the babies there?
I see now.
I would have.
I would literally have to fill this one.
You think?
Maybe?
Wait.
Why, stupid?
Oh.
Wait, come on. Let me jump.
Yeah.
I feel like that's blocked, right?
It's based behind the wall. Oh, is there?
I can't see.
Oh, yes, there is. Thank you, senpai.
Got safety ring.
The heck is a safety ring?
Okay.
Senpai, they're so smart.
Senpai, they're so kind helping me.
I'm like, so head empty. It's like, I'm so tired, but I'm gonna game.
Huh.
What's you're doing on here? Who are you?
What? You're looking for a star? I'll let you see stars are her.
Anyways, you're out of luck.
See, whatever falls in the sea becomes Johnny's property. Got that, matey?
Oh, and one last thing. Read my lips. We ain't letting you through. Got it?
Okay.
Oh, yay.
Alright, you're stronger than you look. Better one that project. Come on, mates.
I thought the boss was the squid. Alright, where's the intruder?
I don't see him. He can't wait.
There he is. Get him, boys.
Here, this one's on us.
How dare you dodge the barrel?
I get up here so fast.
It looks around now. We don't take kindly to strangers here.
Okay.
I'm so bad at the timing.
I'm so bad at the timing right now.
Pretty tough, mate. Alright, I'll let you go through to Johnny's place.
Yo, what? He's like a shark shark.
Wait, he looks like a fake shark, though. Like a skin suit shark?
So you're the Mario, eh? How much to look at?
This star fell into my sea, so it's mine. You want it, you'll have to fight for it.
Oh, come on.
Ah!
Come on. Pick me up.
Ugh. That was not gaming.
Okay.
Is there a max I could do of that?
No.
Ow.
Sorry, I'm so quiet because I'm so tired. I'll get there soon.
I don't know. That was really fun.
Not bad, fellas. How about it, Mario? Mario versus me. Want to mix it up?
Good fun. Good for you, too.
Oh, look alive and cheer me on.
What am I doing?
Okay.
No.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Ow.
Oh, I miss.
Shit.
No, I can't even do that. Okay.
Fuck it. Use it.
Yo.
Oh.
Yay.
I did it.
Life.
I'm so tired.
I thought, I thought the boss, I was like, am I going to, like, just go home?
Like, you know, I'm impressed, matey.
We're in the star.
Like, we're in a souvenir from our fight.
I can't, I can't do a pirate, pirate voice right now.
Look at that.
A star.
And then there's two left. Woo.
Kind of feels good, huh, Senpai?
Are you okay?
Must have really wanted that star.
Now go on, get out of here, change my mind.
And he's our main man, he even fights in his sleep.
I don't want him anywhere.
Off on the trampoline in the next room.
Take you outside. Go on now, give it a try.
Okay.
I now need a save spot.
You found the star, well done.
But your journey ends here, you're so gullible.
Don't you know who I am?
I'm Spirovich, a member of Smithy's gang, shocked.
Aw, fuck.
No wonder my impersonation of an ordinary person was flawless.
Your search for the star has worried Smithy.
If I take that star back, I'll earn bratty points.
It's the way to get ahead.
If you're tired of trying to fight me, just hand it over nice and easy.
Thillius.
How do you want to play it?
What do you think will happen to the real inhabitants of the Seatown?
What are you doing? No, don't do that.
No, please stop.
Fuck.
Aw, there's an innocent shame for an innocent old man to get tickled like that.
Thillius.
No, you wouldn't do it, you're gonna...
No, please not there.
The shame, serious.
Heh heh.
Oh, if you can't cheat me this way!
Ah, yeeah, yeeah, yeeah, yeeah, I can't bear this!
I-I-I think he's dead!
I think he fucking died!
I don't think I have a choice, do I have a choice?
This is a false sense of choice, right?
Hahahahahahahahaha!
I don't think I have a choice.
Do I have a choice?
This is a false sense of choice, right?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
I never had a heart anyways, okay fine
He he he and to think I got the star without even swallowing my hands
Such a genius it scares me sometimes. I wonder I'm so important
All right, everyone listen up. We're returning to the castle. All right. I should be here about right now
I need this you know what?
Oh
And I think
That's it for today senpai
I'm so eepy
so
Oh
It's time
No, yeah, no, yeah
Baby summer yeah, yeah
Only a summer yeah
Sorry about today. He's caught the storm and the storm
The playing hot because I don't have the surge protector or at least my search protectors over a decade old
Yeah, a little bit of rain and then it went away and now we are good beans
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Oh
I am that sleepy and that deep piece I'm fine
That I'm I might not even I might not even be able to
Yeah, that's how it is. I
Might not be able to yeah, because I'm so tired
But
Tomorrow is my SMT
Steam barring
Barring there's nothing that happens that shouldn't uh
It shouldn't be too bad
Yeah
But it's a member's only stream so if you would like to watch it
please upgrade your tier your snippet here or
Member yourself to watch it. We'll be talking about all sorts of things and
I think you really enjoy it
Yeah, usually my membership streams are little more personal I can be a little bit more loosey-goosey than I usually am
As for
Well
As for the day after I have a collab with my sweet dear
Serenity
Who is who is my best friend and I'm so sorry
I'm so tired
Yeah, so we're what's the word we're going over our schedule and
Then after that I will have a break on Sunday
and then
Oh
I will post my schedule on for next week on Sunday on Sunday, so hopefully we'll
We'll have some fun. Yeah, I can actually use my retro take now. So
Yeah, we can we now look forward to next week
I'm gonna next week. I don't think I put Mario on the schedule. So Mario is
Is
What's the word
Mario is on the back burner for now
But we will come back
to
To Mario RPG because it's it's been great fun. It's been great fun
The retro tank and CRT is working. Yes, I've decided to go with
PS2 to for go the CRT idea for now for
PS2 games and instead just hook it up to my my monitor and
It will play smoothly. It will play
better than
then
What I intended
I
The we will probably be the same thing so when I start playing we games I
That's probably gonna be on the bucket list as well as for
But I will if I start playing like
Gamecube or something I will be on the CRT. I have it on a cart
I have the big CRT on the cart
So I'll just have to adjust everything and I'll play it on there and then connected to the PC. Yeah
It sounds good so my ideal was I was originally gonna play everything on CRT, but uh
It's difficult, you know
Who knows I might I might find my final way to do it anyways
TV cart for the CRT is big brain. It's actually like a kitchen cart
It's like a little kitchen cart where you're supposed to put like kitchen stuff
But instead I put the CRT on it so I can wheel it around
Thanks, we're always cooking up great content for us. I think I might not be as creative as my peers
but I try my best to
To to make things
Enjoyable at least I try to do it and try to make it enjoyable visually
Mmm
Hey, don't downplay yourself I feel like I'm not I'm not very creative. It's like I
Don't know. I don't know. I feel like a
Lot of this is me
Selfish selfish me. I want to play these games and therefore you will watch me play these games and enjoy it
I
Feel like it's like that. I I don't make a lot of events and stuff, but I'm definitely kind of like
Yeah, I'm I'm gonna try my best
to make things work and so that we can play all these games that I own and
I'll do like, you know every once in a while
Something different, right? For example, I definitely do have
a
ASMR I'm not sure if I'm gonna call it ASMR
Next week plan. Yeah
I
Also congrats on 6.7 K. Thank you
Let's make it 10. Let's make our let's make it 10 K soon
So close to 6.9 I want it I want it higher
And higher and higher
That's because mama mama kind of scares me right now. She's like
Let's make it 20 K. Fuck it. I believe in you mercy. Oh, you guys all believe in me
Well 69 K. That would be amazing. I would probably take a picture of that
Oh
Gotta get the play button for mama mercy
There's some things that I
Really wanted to do but I think I'll have to put things on the back burner for now because I had some things planned and then I was like, oh
Well, that might have to be saved for later. Oh
but hopefully I can play like all these retro games with some pie and
We'll return back to Mario soon
I want to also play like I want to return to like killer 7 and death mark as well
But you're some games that I have been on my that we've started playing but haven't yet finished
Any hints to tantalize us or
What
Will we get metal gear one day, I don't know it depends on my motion sickness
It'll be my first time playing metal gear, I don't know anything other than people are like, oh, I like this character's butt
Stuff you're putting on the back burner for now. Um, it's a secret
It's a secret but also I cannot
Formulate proper thoughts or cure co coherent sentences in order to explain anything or even be very clever about it
Thinking is hard when E.P
And I am the E.P.I.S.T
of them all
I'm probably gonna head out now
I don't see anyone on because it's pretty late right now, but I hope I get to see you guys
I left the Mario nose on a Maui, I mean the Mercio nose and the Mercio moustache
I
I'll see you all god next time
Scream for mercy
Bye-bye
You